[Musique]
les vagues de la mer sont des baisers
que la mer vient poser quand elle
s'ennuie t'attends
les bagues de la mer sont des baisers
le sol des marins
et tondre ses
mains est une maîtresse
et les bateaux qui vont sur son
dosme un jour que c'est qu'avec
les bagues de la mer sont des cèdre mort
sur les genoux les femmes
et pas que de la mer son dessert
doucement
empoisonné le rats
[Musique]
est une belle
et les bateaux
s'habille de mots
mérité c'est
caresses
[Musique]
de la
mer sont des mouchoirs
S
[Musique]
les vagues de la mer sont des mouchoirs
dans les filles se font parfois des gros
bonheurs
le sort des
barrages étendre ses
mains
[Musique]
resse
et tous les bateaux
qui l'ont dans la peau
meurt d'un jour de
ses caresses
[Musique]